okay so now you get the best bit you
get
first it's the third
kimitachi first
variation second
variation I'm going to do it in slow
motion so you can
[Music]
see so that I'm strong you know because
if I'm there you might HED it and then
as it comes down I come down with
it the timing is you know very difficult
but but that's what you're looking for
so
here you have to pick this one up
because it's not it can't slide so this
one you pick up but you got to be
careful you don't go like that it's got
to slide past the other hand there's so
much detail it that's what I like about
it but
it's you need the roof of the house
since you used to always say you know
the roof of a house will keep you safe
you know this won't cuz your head's
above the roof so so why I like this
particular kimitachi is
because once you do the variations you
really start to see
that
this roof of the
house all right if you don't like you
was under it a bit that's what happens
if if you're too narrow you end up going
oh I only just got out the way that time
but if you got the house you know that
you're always safe under it easier said
and done isn't it okay so one person
will do all three and then the other
person